These two cute koalas
are a background image inside a div.
And right now,
the background size it set to cover.
I want you to compare the difference
between background size cover and
background size contain.
It might help if you
resize the page a bit,
to figure out the difference
between the two.
Once you think you know the difference
between cover and contain,
I have two statements for you.
The first one says that
the image is sized so
that it is as small as possible while
still completely filling its container.
Is that describing contain or cover?
Pick one of the two.
And the second statement says, the image
is sized so that it is as large as
possible while still being completely
visible inside its container.
Is this statement describing contain or
cover?
Pick one of these two.